[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue non pas sur le plateau
de d'interdît d'interdire mais chez moi
je suis confiné comme vous tous nous
allons passer toute cette émission avec
le philosophe edgar morin qui lui aussi
est confiné chez lui
edgar morin qui publie trois livres le
premier c'est les souvenirs viennent à
ma rencontre qui vient de paraître chez
fayard
edgar morin il est difficile de vivre
des choses totalement inédite quand on a
80 18 ans comme vous bientôt 99 ans ce
confinement
c'est quelque chose quand même de
nouveau comment le vivez-vous
écoutez je le vis d'autant mieux que
d'abord ce copil mans se trouve dans un
appartement au doté d'un jardin qui me
permet de sortir dans ce jardin privé
que je suis avec mon épouse est que dans
le fond il ya beaucoup de communication
qui se font par sms donc si vous voulez
je le je le vis non pas comme une chose
privative de communication et de
relation je la vis comme quelque chose
qui incite beaucoup plus à retrouver un
teint d'un temps plus conforme à ma
nature vous je dirais la nature humaine
et dans le faut je le vis dans une
extrême curiosité puisque je m'informe
un peu surtout des développements
multiples de la crise
cette crise à multiples formes qui nous
a prises et donc j'essaie de réfléchir
j'essaie de faire le point donc je le
vis très intensément ce confinement
bien sûr je sais que dans la durée il y
aura un certain nombre peut-être de
problèmes qui viendront mais pour le
moment je suis très stimulé pour essayer
de comprendre un peu ce qui se passe et
puis d'apporter ma contribution
si je peux à éclairer un peu les esprits
alors beaucoup se disent
qui vivent cette période étrange
aujourd'hui se disent ça devait être
comme ça pendant la guerre vous qui avez
connu la guerre la seconde guerre
mondiale vous la raconter en détail
d'ailleurs dans votre livre de souvenirs
est-ce que ça rappelle la guerre l'a
écouté l'analogie re a ses limites
puisque dans le fond actuellement toutes
les contraintes qui nous sont imposées
sont imposés non pas par l'ennemi mais
contre l'ennemi
donc c'est ça qui fait d'abord la
différence
bien entendu l'analogie se trouve dans
le fait que cet ennemi
enfin du moins en ce qui concerne les
résistants dont je faisais partie était
lui-même insaisissable visible c'était
la gestapo parce que l'émir militaires
étaient présents mais l'ennemi qui nous
menaçait directement physiquement
c'était la gestapo rue on le voyait
paille
il pourrait de surprendre comme le virus
et puis si vous voulez y a une chose
peut-être qui va ressembler à la guerre
dont on ne sait pas parce que si le
confinement dur dur a de plus en plus
des limitations au ravitaillement des
manques des choses à des restrictions et
ça pourrait ressembler au type de
restrictions qu'on avait subi pendant
cette période est bien mort 1 dès les
premières pages de votre livre les
souvenirs viennent pas ma rencontre
vous raconter à quel point ça avait mal
commencé pour vous vous étiez mort né
est ce que est ce que ça a une influence
sur le reste de votre et l'existence de
votre très longue existence puisque je
le rappelle vous aurez bientôt 99 ans
écoutez la plus ans manifeste c'est que
depuis ma naissance jusqu'à maintenant
j'ai parfois un sentiment d'étouffement
qui vient du fait que je suis d
complètement asphyxié que le jean est
allumée me gifler pendant pendant
longtemps
donc j'ai eu et vous voulez ce problème
d'asphyxié qui reste avec des sentiments
des équipements mais peut-être aussi que
le fait d'avoir résisté aux produits
abortifs que ma mère pro d'épicier été
condamnés ayant justement il maladive du
dac rite espagnol c'est à dire les
journaux du coeur peut-être que ça
veulent que le foetus qui a résisté à ça
attraper ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
une résilience la capacité de résister à
l'adversité
voilà vous êtes éveillé à la politique
à 16 ans dans les années 30 vous avez
tous vécu de ce xxème siècle vous avez
vécu la montée du fascisme
l'antisémitisme le pacifisme des années
30 et ses erreurs sur lesquels vous
revenez d'ailleurs vous avez vécu la
seconde guerre mondiale l'occupation la
résistance vous avez perdu beaucoup
d'amis vous avez perdu des parents dans
les camps après la guerre vous avez été
membre du parti communiste vous avez
connu le stalinisme c'est-à-dire son
manichéisme sa férocité sont sa bêtise
aussi vous en parler pendant la guerre
froide
là aussi le fanatisme a fait des ravages
et des deux côtés vous étiez aux états
unis au moment de la crise des fusées de
cuba au moment où les états unis ont cru
qu'il y allait y avoir une apocalypse
nucléaire vous avez connu la guerre
d'algérie aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
avez l'impression comme d'autres je me
suis à michel serres qui avait cette
impression de de connaître enfin la paix
c'est à dire qu'au fond nous serions
dans une période plus pacifié que jamais
non une impression bien entendu l'europe
était en paix alors qu'elle était
convulsive faudrait deux guerres
mondiales mais si vous voulez le monde
était toujours agité les vous avez vous
même site et la guerre d'algérie qui
nous a vraiment sollicité et j'ai
l'impression que disons même à l'époque
où qu'on appelait les trente glorieuses
et a eu sept semer 68 qui a montré que
des sous sols de la société n'était pas
stable et moi j'ai si vous voulez j'ai
toujours vécu dans l'idée est que il y
avait à nouveau de nouvelles formes y
d'abord labié barbarie donc qu'on
croyait pouvoir avoir refoulé après la
guerre elle est revenue ici ou là soit
des formes diverses de fanatisme
religieux nationalisme voire de guerre
local donc et nous sommes menacés
aujourd'hui par une barbare et
aujourd'hui d'impôt culte et par le
fléau du virus et d'autre part je pense
que notre propre société notre propre
civilisation secrétaire une forme de
barbarie froide et glacé qui à la
domination du calcul du chiffre et du
pur intérêt
donc si vous voulez moi j'ai
l'impression que sous des formes
nouvelles et qui évidemment ne m est
plus en question ma vie
je me sens toujours en résistance mais
les ennemis ne sont plus les mêmes
et pourtant en dépit de tout ce que vous
avez traversé de toutes les horreurs qui
ont ravagé le 20e siècle
vous restez un humaniste fraternelle
vous avez confiance dans l'être humain
vous pensez qu'il est perfectible
j'avais d'abord j'ai vécu aussi des bons
moments de communion de fraternité
d'amitié d'amour ce sont des expériences
qui ont été très important dans ma vie
parce que je crois que ma capacité de
m'émerveiller et de me réjouir des
beautés de la vie de ce qu'elle apporte
de bons me donne la force de résister à
ces horreurs donc si vous voulez cette
période n'est pas uniquement vu sous
l'angle des phénomènes négatifs et les
vues aussi aux anneaux souza l'autre un
autre anglais restons sur la fraternité
puisque vous lui consacrez également un
livre la fraternité pourquoi qui vient
de paraître chez actes sud
et c'est vrai que votre livre dessous
votre livre de souvenirs et est plein de
moments de fraternité mais entre
individus vous avez connu des amitiés
extraordinaire et voulait raconter en
détail et etc et c'est effectivement
formidable mais la fraternité entre
individus est une chose et la fraternité
entre les masses la fraternité de masse
c'est autre chose on sait que ça peut
donner aussi des formes épouvantable de
manichéisme de xénophobie
d'instinct guerrier ne pensez-vous pas
bien entendu moi je pense que les
paternités les belles phrases yal'idée
sont toujours ouvertes
elles sont jamais fermées
sinon c'est la crédibilité sinon c'est
la fraternité d'un nationalisme agressif
donc non ce boulet pour répondre à votre
question sur la perfectibilité de l'être
humain
je pense que l'être l'être humain a en
lui
les aspects les plus contradictoires si
vous voulez que nous avons besoin de
fraternité et de communion et l'amour
c'est
c'est un besoin fondamental de l'être
humain
les gars morin vous avez été pacifiste
dans les années 30
ça aussi vous le racontez vous avez même
été munichois comme la philosophe simone
weil cela se justifiait pour vous comme
pour elle d'ailleurs elle l'a justifiée
et puis vous avez l'un et l'autre
changer d'avis l'histoire a donné tort
aux munichois
aujourd'hui c'est même devenu
pratiquement une injure à chaque fois
que un conflit menace si l'on n'est pas
d'accord avec la guerre du golfe si on
n'est pas d'accord avec l'invasion de
l'irak
si on n'est pas d'accord avec la guerre
en libye on est traité de munichois
alors il ya parfois les munichois en
raison ça a été le cas pour l'invasion
de l'irak en 2004 on dit que les
munichois avaient raison mais parfois
aussi on dit que les munichois ont tort
ceux qui s'opposaient par exemple au
fait que la france rejoigne la coalition
internationale contre des champs en 2014
alors ce serait quoi la boussole
aujourd'hui à quel moment doit-on
peut-on être munichois est ce que vous
avez trouvé une ligne quelque chose d'un
faillible qui nous permet de de décider
sans avoir peur du regard de l'histoire
j'ai pas trouvé le remède infaillible
ce que je peux dire c'est qu'en
reconsidérant le phénomène de munich
c'est à dire de la capitulation devant
des expositions ce allemande pour la
tchécoslovaquie et l'illusion et était
de ne pas voir que ceux de cette montée
cette volonté hégémonique de l'allemagne
hitlérienne avec son idée d'une race
supérieure qui a été fait pour coloniser
notamment les peuples slaves en europe
on n'avait pas vu que c'était que
c'était sale existentielle on a cru que
en faisant une concession elle même deux
basées sur le droit des peuples à
disposer puisque il y avait une minorité
allemande en tchécoslovaquie
on allait pouvoir calmer
est donc si vous voulez dans chaque cas
il faut voir un peu la situation et
l'art actuellement aujourd'hui pour
l'europe
si on pense à la russie ce n'est pas une
puissance y est animé par une volonté
aujourd'hui hégémonique de dominer le
monde c'est une puissance qui essayent
de rapaces de rassembler des morceaux
d'un ancien empire des jeux dont elle
dort je voulais il faut voir au cas par
cas moi je pose la question de la d
expédition américaine en irak
bien sûr réseau détruit un dictateur
mais son produit des mots innombrables
et je ne suis pas là pour comptabiliser
si les maux provoqués par cette
intervention sont plus grandes que s'il
dictateur qui était mortel avait
continué mais je pense que les
interventions américaines au
moyen-orient où était catastrophique et
ont aggravé le court catastrophique des
choses je pense que chaque situation
méric une un examen une
contextualisations historique et
géographique et qu'on ne peut pas avoir
un principe général aujourd'hui de
pacifisme ou au contraire d'accepter la
guerre la résistance vous aviez 20 ans
vous aviez peur vous le confesser
aujourd'hui vous aviez peur de risquer
votre vie mais dit tu vois en 1942 vivre
ce n'était pas survivre donc risquer sa
vie au fond c'était vivre vivre s'était
risqué sa vie à ce moment-là tout à fait
évident et ce qui était intéressant pour
moi c'est de comprendre la différence
est vide à ce moment-là y éclairante
entre survivre qui était se planquer à
tout prix et vivre qui était évidemment
de riz de risquer sa vie et donc j'ai
fait un peu ce pari et là aussi c'est
vrai que j'ai dû surmonter ma peur mais
comme disait malraux le courage et une
affaire d'organisation
une fois qu'on commence à entrer dans la
clandestinité ou fait des actions de
plus en plus risqué de plus en plus
dangereuse en cours de plus
plus le risque d'être arrêté mais une
fois qu'on est là dedans on s'y installe
on s'y installe c'est comme les pois bus
cette année d'ailleurs de 14
évidemment comment mais je pense que je
veux mais après évidemment il ya le
retour à la vie normale et j'ai perdu si
ici les mêmes événements se répéter
j'avoue que j'en ramassais difficile de
recommencer
le poilu pendant la guerre de 14 il est
obligé d'être dans les tranchées il n'a
pas le choix
de même les marines américains qui
débarque est en normandie en 1944
eux non plus n'avaient pas le choix
quand on est dans la résistance on a le
choix on a choisi vous deviez vous dire
de temps en temps et notamment quand
vous avez risquer la mort à plusieurs
reprises vous n'êtes vous pas dit à quoi
bon finalement le la nécessité qu'il y
aurait à se battre pour un jeune homme
de 20 ans dans la résistance française
n'est pas établi j'imagine vous dites je
pourrais très bien arrêter ça ne
changerait pas le cours de la guerre ça
ne vous a jamais traversé l'esprit
il y avait plusieurs choses qui sont les
qui sont liés
il y avait bien entendu le fait de
lutter contre le nazisme envahisseurs
mais c'était le fait aussi de me les
excuses dans mon esprit était la lutte
de toute l'humanité pour sa libération
je croyais effectivement à l'époque que
le communisme allait perdre tout cette
carence est que dans la victoire et il
verrait qu'une vraie culture fraternelle
c'est pas dur donc il y avait un espoir
un espoir que réelle mais qui s'est
avérée illusoire et en plus ils savaient
à la jeunesse
c'est lourd
la majorité d'entre nous étaient lavés
dans les vingt ans nos chefs nos
responsables il avait 28 30 ans rares
rares étaient les jambes de 40 ans marié
perdre
il ya eu des très courageux donc si vous
voulez ya eu un ensemble de choses qui
auront qui ont joué mais qui m'ont fait
vivre une expérience inoubliable votre
théorie la plus célèbre gare morin c'est
la théorie de la complexité
comme quoi les conséquences d'une
décision peuvent être contraire à ses
intentions et même se retourner se
retourner contre ceux qui ont eu
l'initiative vous raconter dans votre
livre de souvenirs comment elle vous est
venue cette en étudiant la révolution
française et et oui parce que c'était
mon professeur d'histoire de la
révolution georges lefebvre qui nous
enseignait que les états généraux
avaient été déclenchées par la volonté
de l'aristocratie de reconquérir des
pouvoirs qu'elle avait perdue sous la
broye la royauté absolue de louis xiv
pour huit ans de la débilité politique
de louis saez et ce processus
les aristocrates pensait retrouver des
privilèges a déclenché le processus
contraire c'est à dire que quand les
états généraux se saurait et se sont
réunis le tiers et à imposer le vote par
tête et non plus par ordre parce que si
c'est ton beauté selon l'ofs le clergé
l'aristocratie et le tiers état avant
c'était toujours le cas l'arjel
aristocratique elle est la majorité et
cette fois tout changer autrement dit
c'est un des exemples innombrables c'est
comme quand hitler s'est lancé à la
conquête de l'union soviétique
ça c'est absolument retourner vos menée
contre lui comme napoléon donc c'est
très fréquent que des décisions surtout
des défis jour de l'entrée en guerre et
des conséquences absolument contraire à
celle de celui qui est accru les prendre
avec ses propres intentions
c'est vrai que ça s'est vérifié encore
au moment de l'invasion de l'irak par
les états unis
tout s'est retournée contre les états
unis
néanmoins fort de cette théorie de la
complexité des remords 1 vous pourrez
saisir mais il faut en conclure qu'on ne
fait plus rien ça n'est pas votre
conclusion
non au contraire ça permet de voir un
peu le pour et le contre de voir les
différents aspects du problème posé
d'avoir une prise de décision réfléchie
mais vous savez une décision est
toujours un pari est justement dans ma
conception de la complexité
j'insiste pour savoir pour dire que tous
les gens qui prennent des décisions
voire être conscients qu'ils font un
pari c'est à dire qu'il ne voit pas être
sûr des conséquences que la réalité va
imiter celui son boulot et donc je pense
qu'à ce moment là
j'apporte abandonnant la conscience du
paris j'apporte à celui qui va décider
la volonté de suivre par sa stratégie le
cours de l'action de façon à modifier le
cours
si jamais ils dévié par rapport à ce
qu'il a voulu
donc si vous voulez c'est ça aussi la
complexité des gares morale vous insisté
aussi sur les dérives
dit l'histoire provoque des dérives on
s'éloigne insensiblement de nos
croyances de nos idées sans s'en
apercevoir pour nous pour en arriver à
d'autres croyances à d'autres idées
parfois diamétralement opposées c'est
arrivé à un nombre d'intellectuels et
d'hommes politiques français pendant
l'occupation par exemple qui se sont
retrouvés dans la collaboration alors
que ça n'était pas leurs idées ni leurs
croyances
avant-guerre vous-même ça vous est
arrivé quand vous avez adhéré au parti
communiste alors que vous étiez un ace
un anti stalinien
juste avant la guerre alors là aussi
comment faire comment se vacciner contre
les dérives qui nous menace tous
tout à chacun là je pense
qu'effectivement il ya un problème
toto et les âmes un très important de
savoir si et ce qu'on appelle la
fidélité consiste à suivre une voie
auquel ont adhéré avec des intentions
qui ne se réalise pas hé bé qu'il faut
rester fidèle au parti
je pense si vous voulez que tout ceci
nécessite esprit critique auto-examen
attention à la réalité et je pense que
si vous voulez lac la culture que
j'avais acquis à ben guerre était très
critique à l'égard du communisme
stalinien
elle m'est revenue elle m'a permis de
comprendre que les procès aux sorcières
qui était peinte en 1947-48 étaient des
choses immondes et donc qu'ils m'ont
apporté
autrement dit ce qui m'a des convertis
c'est de voir que les carences les
choses affreuses qui était celle de la
bande guerre se répétait après guerre et
donc ça m'a très rapidement si vous
voulez des convertis et ce travail de
des conversions a été capital pour moi
car j'ai fait un livre qui s'appelle
autocritique et où j'ai voulu comprendre
de quelle façon mais je me suis
convaincu qu'il fallait adhérer par des
raisonnements que je croyais rationnelle
et qui en fait était mystico redit
mieux parce que vous savez appartenir au
parti communiste c'était appartenir à
une grande religion du salut terrestre
une religion mondiale mais on ne croyait
que cette et scientifiques fondées sur
les prédictions de la passe et
rationnelle de marx mais en réalité
c'était un acte hyper religieux donc
ciblé il faut faire un travail de
réflexion et de conscience et je pense
que je suis un des rares à avoir fait ce
travail qui m'a conduit à ne plus jamais
jamais utilisé un certain type
d'argument de critiques à dominer mme
des choses disqualifiant les autres j'ai
trop vécu dans un univers où où on s'le
nous ont calomnié on a calomnié les
trotskistes la coloniale et ce qui était
critiqué l'union soviétique
maintenant ça m'a cet examen ou
d'autocritique m'a fait un bien fou et
je crois que maintenant j'ai garde
l'héritage de ça c'est vrai que vous ne
désignez jamais les c'est sans
doute ce qui vous a différencié d'un
jean paul sartre par exemple et d'autres
qui aujourd'hui encore désigne
facilement les mais ça n'est
jamais été votre cas vous et j'essaie de
dire le moins possible et confus à
propos de deux dérives vous parlez de la
dérive stalinienne après la guerre
notamment
mais on pourrait parler aussi de 2
de la dérive qu'on connut un certain
nombre de résistants français ou de
soldats qui s'étaient illustrés dans
l'armée de la france libre pour délivrer
la france mais aussi l'italie du nazisme
et qui pourtant après au moment de la
guerre d'indochine mais surtout au
moment de la guerre d'algérie se sont
conduit souvent de la même manière c'est
à dire ou es ou du torturé on justifier
la torture ou pris des otages ont
assassiné ont persécuté pour des raisons
raciales
tout à coup comme si l'on oubliait
l'homme l'être humain est capable
d'oublier
pourquoi il s'est battu avant et se
battre contre les valeurs qu'ils
défendent mais il ya peu encore il est
capable de se battre contre sous
prétexte que tout à coup les intérêts de
son pays ont changé ça fait peur non
aimé ça vestiaire aussi refermeture des
consciences par exemple la france qui
avait les français qui avaient lutté
pour la liberté contre l'occupation
nazie
au moment où arrive la la la libération
totale la même france réprime à
constantine à sétif d'une manifestation
d'algériens et l'ambassade
donc si vous voulez on avoue de la
liberté pour nous on n'a jamais pensé à
la liberté pour les coloniser
il a fallu tout un travail aussi qui
venu d'abord pas seulement des colonisés
parce que ces gens là ont prise
l'humanisme universaliste que l'europe a
pondu pour dire mais ces choses-là
appliquées lea nous au lieu de vous les
appliquer à nous-mêmes et de ne pas les
appliquer donc si vous voulez ils ont
peu c'est moi je pense que l'humanisme
l'humanisme d'un monteil de montesquieu
d'un i drove c'est ça cette arme qui a
été que les que l'europe colonisatrice
évidemment oublié mais les colonisés eux
mêmes ils ont pris ces arbres pour se
libérer
donc si vous voulez voilà c'est ça les
aléas de l'histoire est bien mort en ont
fait une pause
on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour dans interdit
d'interdire
avec edgar morin et garde morin qui
publie les souvenirs viennent à ma
rencontre chez fayard
vous parlez beaucoup dans ce livre est
de garde du manichéisme on dirait que
c'est votre ennemi principal en tout cas
un de vos ennemis principaux
vous dites que au delà d'un certain
seuil de radicalisation manichéenne tout
devient tiré par able irréconciliables
inexpiable vous dit d'ailleurs que c'est
comme ça que la guerre en ex yougoslavie
s'est déclenchée elle aurait pu
s'arrêter très vite ça a été impossible
parce que tout le monde a fait preuve en
tout cas la plupart ont fait preuve de
manichéisme vous envoyer encore
aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre du manichéisme
aujourd'hui le manichéisme lui-même est
une vision qui est une conséquence ou
l'eau ce privilège soit on the
privilégie soi même en se donnant à soi
toutes les qualités et en donnant à
l'autre tous les vices et toutes les
perversions donc si vous voulez c'est le
nalio le nationalisme clos qui a
provoqué le manichéisme
c'est vrai ça a été vrai parce que la
serbie puis la croatie mêmes sont
devenus des puissances hyper
nationaliste et chacune n'a vu que le
bien dans son action donc si vous voulez
c'est ça qui est très important c'est la
guerre les conditions de guerre des
conditions de fermeture et d'hyper
nationalisme qui favorisent ce
manichéisme où l'ennemi devient bête
immonde à détruire et où soit on est
toujours là toujours raison on est
souvent le bien donc sur vos livres il
faut analyser les causes les causes sont
l'absence totale de complexité dans la
pensée et dans la connaissance c'est
pour ça moi je tiens la complexité l'on
bat pour des raisons maniaque sais pas
ce que c'est parce que oublier à
complexité rend aveugle c'est pascal qui
disait que le contraire d'une vérité
et souvent une vérité contraire donc il
faut comprendre un peu tout ça il faut
comprendre que chez les autres
tous les papes faut il ya peut-être eu
des herbes et recel proust disait que
dans l'antisémitisme
il ya des vérités une vérité devenue
folle quelle est la vérité la vérité
c'est que l'expérience qu'ont subis les
juives pendant des siècles de
persécution et deux ont provoqué un
certain nombre de différences ce qui
fait que bien qu inclus dans les nations
unies l'ont quand même il garde cette
différence qui draps mais cette
différence elle est très compréhensible
mais interprété comme une volonté
nuisibles de dominer le monde et cetera
enfin ce cap et l'antisémitisme ceddat
poli donc si vous voulez il faut essayer
de à mon avis il faut éviter d' état
d'hystérie qui amène à lyncher
médiatiquement ou même physiquement les
gens parce que nous devons toujours être
vigilant à l'égard de nous-mêmes
c'est ça une première leçon capitale
vous parler d'israël également un pays
qui dans l'est dès les années 60 dit
vous avant même la guerre des six-jours
était déjà un pays marqué par la haine
ça vous avez frappé cette présence de
laine dit vous laissant moins une marque
indélébile
même si dit vous également il y avait
des exceptions bien entendu qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
pour que ils n'ont soit pas ainsi
comment est ce qu'on aurait pu concilier
à la fois le le besoin de se défendre
l'état d'israël et puis de l'inspiration
est l'existence d'un état de la part des
palestiniens je crois que vous êtes à la
fois pour que israël puisse défendre son
existence et pour que les la nation
palestinienne puisse aspirer elle aussi
à une existence alors qu'est ce qu'il
aurait fallu pour que les deux soirées
conciliables et pour que ce pays et
cette région ne soit pas divisée comme
elle l'est toujours semble-t-il par len
coûté si les décisions de l'onu qui aura
la part eau qui ont consacré l'existence
et l'indépendance d'israël avait t elle
à ce moment-là respecter y aurait pas eu
ce déchaînement des guerres qui sont
autrement dit le processus de
radicalisation rend de plus en plus
difficile
une solution qui a pu être entrevue
avant l'assassinât de rabin par exemple
il est certain que quand on rentre dans
l'histoire c'est à dire dans les années
20 et 30 l'époque d'un foyer juif en
palestine où il y avait déjà des micros
juif et il y avait une population arabe
il y avait une partie et judéité juifs
avec le philosophe martin buber qui
espéraient un état binational ou les
arabes et les juifs coopérerait effet
cette époque il y avait trop
d'incompréhensions trop d'attentes à
mutuelle pour rendre la chose faisable y
avait aussi le fait que l'hitlérisme est
là le déferlement de l'antisémitisme ne
faisait que des gens comme ben gourion
d'aspirer un état juif et parce que
lydie l'idée était encore dévissé à
nouveau défi qu'elle recommence à
nouveau ce processus où les juifs
dispersés sont victimes
non seulement la ghettoïsation mais
aussi du massacre
donc si vous voulez un moment donné les
choses deviennent très
très difficile à régler et pour le
moment il n'y a aucun règlement possible
est ce que vous voyez s'opérer une
depuis quelques années en france une
radicalisation plutôt des
radicalisations des magnétisme qui sont
en train de se mettre en place et qui
n'étaient pas vraies ou en tout cas
qu'on sentait moins il ya 20 ans il ya
trente ans écoutez je pense que
aujourd'hui le lait crise que nous
subissons un peu ralenti toutes ces
choses là mais il est certain que le
danger était que yens 2 que entre
notamment les les populations musulmanes
d'origine maghrébine ou autre et les
populations de juifs arrivent à des
formes de profits quelle idée violentes
ou ballet population mais de moins que
des minorités non donc si vous voulez ou
jusqu'à présent on est à éviter les
formes les plus violentes
mais le danger et était là la question
est de savoir ce qui va se passer après
la crise mais on pourrait se dire aussi
que ce ce nouvel ennemi invisible qui
qui est le le cornec virus pourrait
aussi tous nous nous réconcilier
certains disaient que pour que les
peuples sur terre serait consigné il
faudrait une invasion extraterrestre là
on a on a le coronel virus ce ne sont
pas des extra ce n'est pas un
extraterrestre mais mais au fond on se
sent tous solidaires les êtres humains
face à lui
c'est ce qu'il aurait dû faire le corps
des virus parce que le coronavirus nous
a montré que la mondialisation
économique aux techniques qui s'est
produite à créer de l'interdépendance
incontestable mais que l'interdépendance
n'a créé aucune solidarité et que à ce
moment là qu'est ce qui s'est passé
l'absence de solidarité fait que quand
arrive le virus et les épidémies chaque
état national se referme sur lui-même
alors que nous sommes en même temps
conscient que c'était une maladie
planétaire qui frappe toute l'humanité
mais nous avons faute aussi bien d'une
conscience collective humaine niveau
planétaire aussi bien lieu de
organisation capable comme le lot et
metz l'onu de coordonner les efforts
différence on se réfugie dans l'égoïsme
national et même le pôle europe on est
très en retard et même pour l'europe
le problème n'était pas de se refermer
sur un égoïsme européen le problème
était d'avoir une solidarité européenne
je pense que c'est très bien qu'il y ait
cette solidarité nationale et cet appel
à ceux de la zale ce serait pas mal
heureux mais il ya aussi une solidarité
humaine devrait comprendre aujourd'hui
le virus nous donner tous nié on est
tous inséparables on est heureux on doit
s'unir et on n'écoute pas la leçon du
virus
d'autres pensent que cette crise que
nous traversons c'est confinement le
fait que là tout à coup on cesse de
travailler en tout cas beaucoup d'entre
nous ont cessé de travailler
on ne circule plus les avions restent au
sol
on ne peut lui plus vous qui avez été
l'un des premiers écologie vous avez été
un écologiste prémonitoire est ce que
vous y voyez une répétition générale là
encore on a eu beaucoup de mal à se
mobiliser dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique on a vu des
enfants le faire derrière gratuit berg
des adolescents - souvent les adultes et
notamment les chefs d'état alors est-ce
que tout à coup la avec le coronavirus
on n'a pas tout à coup pris conscience
qu'on pouvait agir sur et puis on se
rend compte aujourd'hui que par exemple
dans des régions de chine
la pollution a beaucoup dit ce père a
beaucoup diminué
donc bien sûr il est évident que ce
qu'on appelle là que la crise économique
qui ait résolu qui est issu de la crise
sanitaire elle même en rallye dans les
activités elle même à sydney un peu la
planète mais c'est payé très cher
effectivement une conquête écologique
par les dégradations parce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui une triple crise
d'abord c'est pas seulement la crise de
l'épidémie et des crises donc sanitaire
nous avons elle a déclenché une crise
économique
et cette crise économique avec les
arrêts tous que ça produit elle même et
les deux crises déclenché une crise de
civilisation c'est à dire que nous
sommes obligés de changer tous nos
comportements normaux de civilisation de
gens extravertis qui sortons pour le
travail qu'ils sentons pour les fêtes
qui sont ont pour les sorties qui sont
tous pour les restaurants pour le cinéma
a brusquement de tout changer et de
contrôler notre comme notre consommation
de repenser à la vie que nous venions de
voir que c'était pas seulement une vie
qui jouissait de liberté mais une vie
aussi qu'ils étaient dans la
superficialité et qui en plus est
peut-être était elle même en cours de
dégradation avec ce qu'on peut appeler
le le consumérisme c'est à dire qui
n'est pas la consommation qui est la
diction la drogue qu'on sur balles
la consommation r la consommation comme
toxiques
avec tous ces produits qui ne servent à
rien qu'ils sont eux qui ont des vertus
l'hisoire monté par la publicité
donc si vous voulez il ya une réflexion
qui peut aujourd'hui venir et n'être ont
deux de cette crise le jeu roi et
j'espère que tout ce qu'on peut faire
pour nous donner cette confiance sera
bonne
mais je répète il faut penser que les
trois crises sont toutes les trois
planétaires sont toutes les trois une
crise de l'humanité
ça c'est certain il faut en tirer les
conséquences dans introduction à la
pensée complexe en 1990 vous écriviez
que nous étions à la fin d'un temps pour
vous c'était la fin d'une époque la fin
d'un cycle je ne serai pas comment
l'appeler mais que nous étions déjà à ce
moment là au commencement des temps
nouveaux
ces temps nouveaux ont ils véritablement
commencé et est accolée reconnaît-on
savez c'est un nouveau ont commencé par
cette une
vous savez l'air planétaire de
l'humanité a commencé avec la conquête
des amériques la navigation autour du
globe en 14 ans 92 bon à ce moment là il
ya eu des jets d'unification microbienne
du globe
c'est à dire que tous nos microbes
européen on les a donnés aux américains
hellebuyck rock américain on les a pris
donc l'unification microbienne elle a
déjà du début du xvième siècle et puis
après les tomates le maïs tous ces
choses là qui sont venus d'amérique le
cheval qui donc a eu beaucoup de choses
qui se répète mais l'élément nouveau
c'est quand il ya eu cette unification
technico économique après l'effondrement
de l'union soviétique c'est à dire que
le marché le capitalisme se sont
introduits par tous à seulement dans la
russie mais y compris en chine
c'est créer une alliance tout à fait
étonnante entre la dictature d'un parti
totalitaire et disons le développement
du profit capitaliste
donc il ya eu cette unification au même
moment grâce à internet grâce à interpol
grâce à touvre on communique de tous les
coins du monde et malgré ce fait qu' il
ya cette unification technique et
communicationnel on se comprend de moins
en moins les yougoslaves se sont
désintégrées à ce moment là justement
les legs et dans le fossé
c'est ça le point essentiel ça a créé
une interdépendance sans créer la
solidarité et en créant souvent au
contraire der fermeture sur soi sur sa
culture compense menacé par
l'occidentalisation que c'est un donc
voilà le grand problème il faut repenser
la globalisation il faut repenser la
politique économique est fondé sur le
néolibéralisme depuis padam thatcher et
monsieur reggane et que tout ceci
aujourd'hui près déjà et balayez c'était
extraordinaire de voir que aujourd'hui 2
après que partout que l'europe ait
poussé pendant des années à diminuer les
crédits d pour les hôpitaux et pour que
des hôpitaux deviennent comme des
entreprises commerciales privées faisant
des bénéfices à part on a vu maintenant
le désastre de cette politique
on le voit dans les services publics
sont vitaux les le rôle de l'état et est
capital ce qui n'empêche pas de boire
qu'au péril les autres états il ya une
repenser total de la politique est
nécessaire et moi j'espère avoir fait ma
contribution quand j'écris bon livre qui
s'appelle la voie parce que les chats
cette époque j'ai montré comment il
fallait choisir et perspectives et
aujourd'hui vous sortez pour changer de
civilisation c'est un livre d'entretiens
qui vient de paraître aux éditions de
l'aube
c'est toujours la même idée
vous préconisez toujours les mêmes
choses à peu près pas toujours se dire
que vous savez à partir des mois si vous
voulez à partir de la fin du siècle
dernier
j'ai été convertis à ce qu'on peut
appeler de l'alter mondialisme c'est à
dire non pas contre eux le phénomène de
la multiplication des communications
mondiales au contraire moi je me suis
aussi citoyen du monde
j'étais plus partie du comité des stores
et du monde de gary d'avis en 1960
donc si vous voulez moi je suis pas pour
la fermeture mais je suis aussi pour le
respect des ratios et de patrie pour
combiner un peu tout ça donc si vous
voulez j'ai commencé à se demander et g
et en réfléchissant de plus en plus
c'est pas des échanges et même les
principes de l'action politique et de la
réforme politique
ce que je fais dans la voix ça c'est le
travail que j'ai fait vers did 2010
excepté le livre est sorti je crois en
donc si vous voulez ça c'est une chose
qui est fondamental pour moi de penser
l'air planétaire de penser les
conséquences de tout ceci de penser ce
qu'on peut faire
pas seulement à l'échelle du monde parce
qu'on ne peut rien faire pour le moment
mais au moins déjà l'échelle de la
nation
et ça c'est important et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on voit que l'on peut
faire des choses j'ai l'impression là
aussi c'est votre manière à vous de
lutter contre le manichéisme vous
essayez souvent et notamment dans la
voix de de réconcilier ce que d'autres
pourraient penser comme commettre d'aidé
contraire vous êtes à la fois venait pas
contre l'individualisme mais vous êtes
aussi pour le collectif
vous n'êtes pas contre la nation vous
être en faveur des supprimé de la
supranationalité pour vous à chaque fois
on peut on doit pas tranché de façon de
façon rigide au contraire je lutte
contre cette dichotomie barbares qui
elle nous est imposée aux new dit
mondialisation ou démondialisation moi
je dis pour continuer le meilleur de la
mondialisation donc les coopérations et
démondialiser les territoires qu'il faut
sauver il faut sauver l'autonomie
vivrière de pays comme la france il faut
sauver l'autonomie sanitaire d'un pays
comme la france est comme tous les on
paie il faut sauver les territoires qui
est son désert qui deviennent
désertifier à cause la mondialisation
donc il faut mondialisée démondialiser
et pour croissance et décroissance au
lieu de ne poser pourquoi parce qu'il ya
des choses qui doivent croître
toute l'économie solidaire toute
l'économie des produits nécessaires à la
vie des produits sains et en même temps
ce qu'il voit décroître ces les produits
futile sans intérêt absolue sens propre
avec ce terrain on doit faire de tableau
chico revoir ce qui doit décroître
autrement dit ces idées qui semblent
osera dit ouah il faut lier et voix je
dirais développement et enveloppements
le développement est purement technique
économique
sa forte aussi des gris cheveux ça
détruit les solidarités dans des
civilisations traditionnelles bien
entendu sa porte beaucoup davantage
beaucoup d'autonomie individuelle mais
sa porte et donc c'est pour ça il faut
prendre les aspects positifs de
développement mais gardez les
communautés ce que j'appelle dans
l'augmentant à vos besoins chaque
personne en tant que moi en tant que je
voit s'épanouir mais toujours dans le
cadre d'une communion d'une communauté
que ce soit la famille des amis
la fraternité c'est ça qui est très
important
donc si vous voulez voilà des choses que
qui semblent incompatibles entre le mois
et le nous
non il ya le mois s'il n'est pas dans le
new devient égoïste et le loup s'il
oublier le mois fait de nous des
fanatiques comme l'ont fait les
richesses et donc moi ce qui me semble
évident mais pour vous des gens ne l'est
pas parce que ils vivent dans ces
catégories binaire oui ou non
et moi je pense qu'il faut associer des
choses qui leur semble le contraire est
bien mort 1 votre livre de souvenirs ne
fait pas long l'impasse sur la sexualité
et on s'aperçoit on parle souvent de la
libération sexuelle des années 60 mais
en vous lisant on s'aperçoit que on n'a
pas attendu les années 60 pour être
libre vous parler notamment de
marguerite duras qui est une femme
extrêmement libre à son époque aussi
libre voire plus libre que beaucoup de
femmes d'aujourd'hui
là aussi on dirait que c'était s'est de
tout temps au fond la liberté a toujours
existé les gens savent plus ou moins
s'en emparer de ce point de vue là là
aussi il ya un problème de liberté et de
régulation il ya un problème de fidélité
[Musique]
ce sont des problèmes
chacun doit mener sa vie privée en pompe
jour des exigences qui sont parfois
contradictoires
une fois qu'on est lié il ya quelque
chose qui est qui nous engage et en même
temps regarder des libertés se vous
savez moi je pense que là ya pas de
recette
il ya toujours amené en soi même ce que
j'appelle un une sorte de dialogue
contradictoire entre la raison et la
passion et ça c'est d'autres conditions
s'il nous est aux finitions à la raison
froide
nous cessons d'être humain suivez ici
nous obéissons à la passion aveugle de
blonde est fou alors entre le délire
et la véraison delà c'est le calcul nous
devons habillé de nouveau essayé d'être
l'om le métier d'être humain est un
métier très difficile et c'est dommage
qu'on n'enseigne pas dans nos écoles
vous dites aussi dans votre livre quand
en juin 40 la sexualité se libère et
vous ajoutez comme dans toutes les
périodes où ça fesse les sociétés quel
est le rapport à votre avis entre entre
l'affaissement d'une société son
effondrement et la liberté sexuelle
pourquoi est ce que l'un va souvent de
la véraison avec l'autre mais vous savez
à mon avis la liberté d pas la licence
n'était pas le voit de tout faire je
pense que là c'est l'effondrement des
sociétés mais bien d'un ensemble de
causes qui les désintègre de l'intérieur
là aussi une société elle a besoin de
deux communautés
elle a besoin de relations houleuses son
père parti d'un tout si on n'a pas ce
sentiment de responsabilité à l'égard du
tout à ce moment là la cohésion de petr
menuck par des moyens brutaux de
contraintes
donc moi je rêve d'une société où
effectivement il y aurait beaucoup plus
de liberté mais parce que norway soi
même beaucoup plus le sens des autres de
la communauté salamé c'est un rêve
merci les gars morin pour cet entretien
portez vous bien je rappelle que les
souvenirs reviennent à ma rencontre
votre livre vient de paraître chez
fayard mais il y a également pour
changer de civilisation un livre
d'entretiens qui est paru aux éditions
de l'aube et et la fraternité pourquoi
qui est paru chez actes sud portez vous
bien et j'espère à bientôt
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
je